this podcast is about what we just did
yes about Grievances and being real
right and history and all that stuff yes
let's not [__] put icing on this cake
yeah absolutely let's put icing
depression he can't do it okay it's too
hard
it's coming yeah yeah yeah uh let me
just do three man I'll give you one out
you already okay I'll give you one
impression I can't believe this and then
you gotta do one I don't do Impressions
I have to try it no no all right let's
see if we can guess who it is let's play
that goal yeah it'll be easy to guess
who it is no I don't know people he
doesn't know he really does I really
don't know people right as soon as I
make the face you'll know okay go on go
Bill Cosby
that's fine Bill Cosby Bill Cosby okay
yeah uh are you Spanish I'm Filipino
really yeah okay you know I thought you
was Spanish to see
to make you a drink by me called the
penis colada
okay do another face see if I can guess
it
oh [__] do you know it before you know
anything
I don't know I think so oh
I think is it not Shaq Shaq right yeah
well that's Jack okay
[Laughter]
it's incredible do another one [__]
cyber you really want to check out the
[__]
yeah
assistant
that's incredible thank you sir do
another one well now I'm done [__] no
no no n word start with a face I like
this game start with the face
go to the Evergreen ones that are like
let's start difficult first
but nobody else has a face did Arrow
does yeah but I don't do dinero dude
all right
everyone doesn't walk in can you do a
walking it's terrible uh why
that's dead of us pretty good yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah Jeff Goldblum
it's like a Special Olympics kid
you know I gotta be honest I stopped
doing Denzel why because there's a guy
that does Denzel that puts all of us to
shame the people that are known for
doing Denzel who gives a [__] Reggie Reg
me uh not afion Godfrey
um
um there's a brother out of Brooklyn uh
named C King when I tell you he does
Denzel like uh Frank does Madden it puts
us to shape oh I see so I stopped I was
like I do it
my
uh Bobby you making me laugh I can't do
it damn [__] don't say that go all
right all right all right that was great
that's all I want is one word yeah all
you missing Kim Jong uniform let's go
more difficult
oh my God
uh uh Dennis Rodman uh I don't know what
he sounds like but
that's very good like I said you're one
of the best Impressions I've ever seen
But I just I've always I don't want to
be known for just that I'm not a one
trick and and during this [__]
podcast you got huge laughs with just
being you dude okay so we [__] know
already bro all right we already know it
dude all right chill bro I really like
this podcast I really this is a great
one you both really just grew up we grew
up here yes never we're never gonna do
this again we're never gonna talk [__]
we're not my God's honor my dick is as
big as Bobby Lee
my [__] has the girl I think it's good